education is in fact about pushing a
political agenda that is the point of
public education public and political
mean the exact same thing
political is another word for public
it's the stuff that we all do together
not in our little private lives not in
the recesses of our own mind but
together so when when DeSantis says
education is about pursuing truth not
about a political agenda he's half right
it is about pursuing truth but it is
also about applying those truths to the
political situation education is about
creating citizens education is about
inculcating a Civic spirit in people
education is about creating the next
generation of Americans who are going to
build up our country and live together
education is how we are raised and the
question of how we are raised and how we
behave and what we believe and how we
view our fellow countrymen and how we
view our country that is a deeply
political question